اعلنت اوكرانيا حاله التاهب الجوي في عموم
البلاد واكدت ان روسيا استهدفتها بنحو 163
صاروخا خلال الساعات الماضيه كما حذرت كيف
من ان موسكو تحضر لعمليه واسعه ضدها بدايه
العام القادم من جانبها اكدت روسيا تكثيف
ضربتها الجويه على اوكرانيا يوم الجمعه
بما عطل نقل اسلحه غربيه اليها بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مصارعه هي الاهداف التي تسعى
روسيا الى تحقيقها بتكثيف ضربتها الجويه
على اوكرانيا وما المعطيات التي اختارت
وفقها توقيت هذا التصعيد وما مدى دقه
التحذيرات اوكرانيا من ما تسميه عمليه
الروسيه واسعه ضدها العمل المقبل وعلى اي
نحو سيتعامل الغرب مع مثل هذا السنه اليوم
كيف ستنعكس موجه تصعيد الاخيره للحرب في
اوكرانيا على مسار تطورات الميدانيه
والسياسيه في اطار النزاع الروسي مع كافل
[موسيقى]
في سياقه الصعيدي عند القصف الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تقول احصائيات ان موسكو اطلقت
نحو الف صاروخ وطائره مسيره منذ منتصف
اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني وحاله التاهب الجوي في عموم
البلاد وحذر من ما سماها موجات هجمات
روسيه جديده هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه قالت
ان قواتها صدت هجوم الروسيه على اكثر من
20 بلده في مقاطعه دونيسك وان نحو 25 قريه
اخرى في محيط مدينه بخموت تعرضت لقصف
الروسيه كثير
الهيئه واضافت ايضا ان القوات الروسيه
تستهدفت الاراضي الاوكرانيه بنحو مائه و
163 صاروخا خلال الساعات الماضيه اما
قياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه فقد قالت
ان القصف الروسيه استمر على مرافق البنيه
التحتيه في مقاطع
انها الدفاعاتها الجويه اسقطت صاروخين
روسيين اطلقا من شبه جزيره القرم اما في
خرسون ففاد مراسل الجزيره باستمرار القصف
المدفعي المتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه على طول ضفتي نهر دنفر
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اكدت من جانبها
تنفيذ ما وصفتها بضربات جويه وبحريه عاليه
الدقه قالت انها عطلت امدادات التسليح
الغربي لاوكرانيا التي ارتفع الحديد في
اطارها خلال الايام الماضيه عن موافقه
واشنطن على امداد كياف بنظام الدفاع الجوي
باتريات المتحدث باسم الوزاره شنكوف اكد
ان الضربات التي تمت الجمعه حققت جميع
اهدافها
تعرضت امس انظمه القياده والسيطره
العسكريه
الصناعي ومنشات الطاقه الاوكرانيه لضربات
ضخمه باسلحه جويه وبحريه عاليه الدقه
بعيده المدى وحققت الضربه جميع اهدافها
وقد تعطلت مؤسسات الدفاع الاوكرانيه
لانتاج واصلاح الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
والذخيره ودمرنا اربع محطات رادار
اوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
مناقصه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسيقى
الدكتور
الهدف بسيط يا اجبار الطرف الاوكراني
لاستئناف المفاوضات
بسبب ان قبل قبل اللجوء الى هذه الادوات
اي استهداف البنيه تحتيه الاوكرانيه روسيا
قد ركزت على ساحه القطاعات وعلى ما يبدو
قد حاولت وفكرت بان يمكن بعد سلسله
العمليه القتاليه تواصل الى فكره همم
ايقافه
والحوار مع الجنب الاوكراني ولكن اوكرانيا
ترفض ذلك يرفض ذلك علاوه قد لجئت اوكراني
الى تنفيذ العمليات الارهابيه في الاراده
الروسيه
تفجير همم
طردنا سياره لفانوس
ان افترضنا بان ذلك هو ان يحق الجانب
الاوكراني على الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
لماذا في هذا التوقيت منذ اكتوبر الى
اليوم تكثف روسيا ضربتها على اوكرانيا
وهذه الوتيره ترتفع يوما بعد يوم
هذا المقصوده يعني روسيا قد لجات الى
استهداف اوكرانيا بشكل مكثف قبل كل شيء
بني تحتيه الاوكرانيه الكهربائيه بعد
تفجير جسر القرم ف- همم تجاوز اوكرانيا كل
الخطوط الحمراء بالنسبه
الادوات الجديده هل في نفس الوقت توجد
لتكثيف الضربات بني تحتيه الاخرى سكك
الحديد غيرها من الاماكن همم اوكرانيا
ولكن في هذه المعطاف انا اعتقد نشاهده
تكثيف الضربات قبل نهايه هذا العام يعني
تعبير لقطع اكثريه او ربما حتى كل
الامدادات الكهرباء همم
للجيش الاوكراني فبتابع الحل من جديد يقول
الهدف الرئيسي هو اجبار اوكرانيا للجلوس
الحوار دكتور دونالدز جينسن القوات
الروسيه بح بقى الجانب الاوكراني استهدفت
الاراضي الاوكرانيه بنحو 163 صاروخا خلال
الساعات الماضيه كيف تقراون هذا التصعيد
وما اهدافه بتقديره
انا الان على خلافه ضيفكم الرئيس الذي
تفسير مختلف الامر هل نظرا لاداء السيئه
للاقامه الروسيه فانه يقرر تدمير اوكرانيا
بكاملها وهذا يعني
خطه القياده السيئه في موسكو وهذا يعرف
اداء الضباطها وهذا ايضا كل شيء قوه فعليه
الجيش الاوكرانيا اين سيؤدي هذا الامر
بالتاكيد هناك حرب الجيش الروسي وعودا
نوضح بان 70 80% من مسيرات الروسيه
والصواريخ تسقطها قوات الدفاع الجوي
اذا في الخطه الاساسيه لروسيا قد اخفقت
وبدل التراجع
هذا الهجوم وزياده وهذا بالنسبه لمؤشر على
الشهور بالياس
لمحاوله تحقيق شيء اخر لان الجيش لم يحقق
شيئا هل ان هذا سيدفع بالاطراف الى ماء
المفاوضات كلا لا اعتقد ذلك فاكرين اذا
تمتلك ما زال لمبادره في ساحه المعارك وقد
قاده اوكرانيا لن تدخل في مفاوضات الى بعد
همم
اراضيها وروسيا حسب علمي لم تغير موقفها
تفاوضي منذ في الراي بدايه مارس اذا في
الحين المفاوضات قد تاتي اني ربما في
السنه القادمه لكننا مازلنا بعيدين عن ذلك
الان وسندري المزيد والمزيد من شاهدنا من
اعمال هجمات الوحشيه يقوم بها دروس على
المدنيين واستمرار النجاح القوات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه
كثير
في الشتاء هذا امر علينا ننتظر
هل ما تقوم به روسيا اليوم من تكثيف
لضربتها على اوكرانيا هي لدفع الجانب
الاوكراني الى طاوله المفاوضات ام للتغطيه
على اخفاقاتها في ارض المعركه
والصعوبات لدروسه في على صحه القتال من
جديد يقول روسيا اقتصرت منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بادوات قليله جدا
يعني كان هناك تركيز فقط على ساحه القتال
همم روسيا لم تلجا الى ضربات الدنيا تحتيه
كما مثلا قامت به الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في العراق في ليبيا في غيرها من
الاماكن في صلاله حتى يعني من جديد اقول
روسي قد حاولت ان تقتصر بفقد ساحه القتال
ولسم لجل يوصل المفاوضات مع الجانب
الاوكراني له مناقشه المسائل الحيويه ولكن
شاهدنا للعمليات الارهابيه خاصه ضد جسر
الخير من قبل القياده الاوكرانيه فطبعا
هذا ما دفعت روسيا الى اللجوء الى الادوات
الجديده ولكن في هذه المطار الهدف الرئيسي
بالنسبه
للحوار مناقشه المخاوف الامنيه الروسيه
ربما فقط مع الجن بالاوكراني بالكذلك مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا ما هنالك
المتحده
من ربط بين هذا التكثيف
وقرار الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بتزويد
اوكرانيا بسواريخ باتريات وهي كانت عقده
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب ما ما واجهت هذا
الرابط
بشكل نهائي
الى اوكرانيا وبالتالي لكن المشكله انها
غاليه جدا
وبالتالي علينا ان ننظر من الذي سيحصل
بالتاكيد ان الشركه الغربي
لمواجهه الخدمات هجمات
المدنيه لكن
وغضب
الكريمليل حول تجهيزه هذه المنظمات
دائما يتحدثون في اشياء ولكن في الواقع
دائما تكون الافعالهم ما يقولونهم لكن
نظيف العسكريه
روسيا على انها هجمات كما قال للضيف الاخر
فهذه هجمات مشروعه ويحقوا الاوكرانيين ان
يدافع عن انسان فهم تعرضوا للغزو فاذا هجم
جسرا في في القلم او في زمن رجع وغيرها
فهذه كلها اراضي اوكرانيه
واوكرانيها
عندما تحتلها قوه اجنبيه محتله وان يدفعوا
هذه القوه
الاوكرانيه من عمليه واسعه هذا الشتاء
ينسى السولتنبر بموازازات التحضيرات
الاوكرانيه قال ان حربه روسيا على
اوكرانيا قد تستمر لفتره طويله لكنها
ستنتهي على طاوله المفاوضات بحسب قوله
وداع الامين العام لحلف الناته الى عدم
التقليل من شان روسيا لكونها تخطط لعمليه
عسكريه طويله وفقه تعبيره امين اللي عامله
النت وشدد ايضا على ضروره ان يضمن اي حل
مستقبليا للازمه انتصار اوكرانيا كدوله
مستقله وذات السياده واكد ان اسرع طريقه
لتحقيق ذلك هي زياده الدعم العسكري
تصريحات التزامنت مع اجتماع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتن يوم الجمعه بقاده مراكز
عمليات المشاركه في اوكرانيا في مركز
القياده الذي لم يكشف عن موقعه وبحسب
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
واعرب لقادتها عن استعداده الاستماع الى
مقترحاتهم بشان الاجراءات الفوليه
والمتوسطه المدى فيما يتعلق بسير العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا اعود اليك سيد
اندريه من جديد الى انطلق مما ذكرنا في
نهايه هذا الخبر اللقاء الذي جمع بوتن مع
قيادات عسكريه
واستعداده لمقتراحات جديده اي دلالات يحمل
هل يشكل ذلك دليلا على ان روسيا مافيا في
توسيع عمليتها
انا اعتقد ذلك بسبب ااا على الاقل يمكن ان
نفترض ان هذا كان هدف لجراء تعبئه الجزئيه
في روسيا هذا شيء شيء ثاني هناك معلومات
وشاعيات تصل الينا من اوكرانيا بان الجيش
الاوكراني يعاني من نقص القنابل المدفعيه
وكذلك هناك تقليص في دعم العسكري من الدول
الغربيه كل ذلك يشكل فرص جيده بنسبه للجيش
الروسي للاخواتها الروسيه
اوكرانيا
او يقلص من تسريحه اوكرانيا في وقت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتحدث عن
منظومه باتريات وهي التي كانت ترفض سابقا
تزويد اوكرانيا بها
امريكا تتحدث عن منظومات قطر ليس الان
ولكن منذ الفتره وانا اتفق مع ضيفكم في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان هي مساله
صعبه جدا بسبب منظومات بيتريود هي منظومات
غاليه وصواريخ التي تلك المعلومات غاليه
جدا ولكن في نفس الوقت روسيا تستعمل
مسيرات رخيصه نسبيا هل فعلا تريده واشنطن
استعمال مثل هذه الصواريخ ضد المصري
اساسها بينهم
استنتاجاتكم بان الغرب يقلص من تسليحه
لاوكرانيا
هناك كثير من الشعيرات تصل من صفوف
الاوكرانيين بان هناك ضغطه همم على الجانب
الاوكراني من قبل الدول الغربيه ليجلس الى
دور الحوار مع روسيا فلذلك مساله التقليس
لتصليح الجيش الاوكراني من قبل الدول
الغربيه همم هو يتم استعمالها لاجل الضغط
على السلطات الاوكرانيه هذه هي طبعا
معلومات غير المؤكده ولكن تلك المعلومات
تصل الينا من جديد يقول همم المساله
المنظومه لما
يتخذ القرار بعد حول هذا الموضوع وكذلك
انا ودا نشير الى نقطه مهمه جدا
نحن قد دخلنا الى حاله الاستنظار في
المتبادل ليس بين روسيا اوكرانيا قبل كل
شيء بين روسيا ودول الغربيه روسيا مستمر
الدول الغربيه
في المقابل الجانب الاوكراني يتوقع هجوم
موسع على همم اوكرانيا من قبل الجانب
الروسي ايضا سولتنبر تحدث عن حرب طويله
المدى على ماذا تبنى هذه الاستنتاجات هل
على ادله معطيات ام نحن نتحدث عن توقعات
من قبل الغرب واوكرانيا
بامكانيات احتمالات في روسيا تحاول تعزيز
قوتها الناظور الرئيس ارسال القوات غير
مدربه
الحقائق في اوكرانيا هل ان هذا سيؤدي الى
هجوم وسع من قبل روسيا في الشتاء
ذلك اعتقد ان كان العسكريه
يتحدث
لكل الاحتمالات
والحاليا لا ارى خاصه عبر الخطوط الجبهه
لا ارى ان روسيا القدره على قيام به هجوم
واسع لكن ذلك لابد ان قد يحصل لابد كيف ان
تستعد له ولكن كيف تتحدث عن ارقام معينه
قائد القوات المسلحه قال لمجله الروسي
يعدونا حوالي 200 جندي جديد هل يمكن ان
يكون ذلك يدخنون الخطر من اجل المزيد من
الاسلحه والدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا
فهم احتياجات كبيره ولابد ان يستعد لهم اي
اعتماد فمثلا سواء القادم سيكون
من الشمال وهذا قد يحصل الجيش
مره اخرى وبالتالي لكن على القران
اعتقد ان القوات العسكريه الروسيه لن
تستطيع القوات التي عليها
اعود مره جديده اليك سيد اندريس سيد
اندرياس اشرت بان الحرب دخلت مرحله
الاستنزاف ستولتنبر الامين العام لحلفي
شمال الاطلسيه يقول ان الحرب ستطول ولكن
بالنهايه سنعود الى طاوله المفاوضات بشرط
ان يكون اي حل مستقبلي للازمه ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار انتصار اوكرانيا كدوله مستقله
وذات سياده وهذه اسرع طريقه هل روسيا
مستعده للجلوس وفق هذه الشروط
يمكن ان نختار يوم السياده الاوكرانيه
ولكن مبنيا على الواقع الذي قد تشكل على
ساحه القتال هناك اربع لمناطق الجديده
التي كذلك قبل ذلك القرم والتي اتخذت
القرار حول انضمام الى صفوف الاراضي
الروسيه وكذلك يجب ان نناقش المسائل
المخاوف والامنيه الروسيه انا اعتقد ان
اسبب الرئيسي بدا هذه العمليه العسكريه
كان ان امريكا وحلف النت وقد رفض يعني
نقاش حول مخاوف الامنيه الروسيه تقديم
الضمانات الامنيه الروسيه التي طلبتها
موسكو منه واشنطن همم شيء ثاني يعني يمكن
ان نقول ان الصوت همم يقوم بهذا التصريح
وقد يتغير تصريح في المستقبل يعني قد
تستمر
في ما يتعلق بنهايه المطافي المفاوضات
مفهوم السياده يبدو لدى روسيا مختلف عن
المفهوم التقليدي يعني نحترم السياده ولكن
مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار الحقائق على الارض
مدى استعداد اوكرانيا للتسليم بذلك ومن
خلفها الغرب الا يعتبر ذلك واقعيه
روسيا حول ما تريد
الدوله
النظام الامني او الاقتصادي الاوروبي وهذا
لن يتغير طالما ان الطرفين همم مختلفان في
ذلك كما قال زميلي الروسي
همم
اي همم
لم تكن جزءا من روسيا ابدا ان تكون كذلك
والواقع ان هذه كلها مخططات انت رياليه
وعدده همم
الديمقراطيه المسالمه
وليستطيع الاعلام
الامريكي السابق في موسكو وشكر موصول
للسيد اندرياس الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من
موسكو ايضا
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]